What happens if instead of there being
an acute infection or a good vaccine
that gives you this long lived memory
responses... What will happen if you have
a persistent infection -- that is. you have a
chronic infection, like you have in HIV,
hepatitis B virus infection, or hepatitis
C virus infection, or you would have in
many tumors ,because the tumor antigen is
there continuously. So in an acute
infection setting, where the T-cell is
stimulated for a short period, it gets
all the right cues and all the
right buttons are pushed, so you generate
these highly functional memory cells.
What would happen if that antigen does
not disappear and continues to
stimulate the T-cell?
Before we made the discovery that T-cells are functionally exhausted it was known --
work that actually we had done and many other
people had done -- that if there is a
chronic infection and you try
to measure a T-cell or even
sometimes a B-cell ,but certainly when you try
to measure a T-cell response against
that particular chronic infection,
you couldn't detect those cells by
functional assays. Those were
the only assays that were available.
And the assumption was that either the T-cells
are not there or they were never generated.
So the fact that there was a
decreased immune response against a
chronic pathogen was known. In fact we
had published a paper on this many years
back in the 1980s, but the basis for that
that - this non-responsiveness - was not known
and most people had assumed that the T-cells
were not there, that they were deleted.
In fact that was a favorite hypotheses  -
that you delete antigen reactive T-cells
or self-reactive T-cells
in the thymus and
so you have this clonal deletion
and you don't have the T-cells.
Or the  virus did something to inhibit the
generation of this T-cell response.
So immune suppression by the virus to
inhibit the response or the deletion of
these cells were the two major
mechanisms for not being able to control
a chronic infection. And that of course
also extended to the tumor setting.
So we then again modeled these studies in in
the mouse model that we use to study the
good memory cell generation.
So then we got a very interesting result.
We found that when there is a chronic
antigenic stimulation, the T-cells
actually get functionally exhausted,
and that was a paradigm shift, because if
the T-cells are there, that means you can
try and fix things. If they're dead
there's nothing you can do. If they were
not generated, there's not a whole lot
that you can do. So that was a paradigm
shift in terms of showing that the
T-cells are physically present but they're
dysfunctional. So the T-cells are
physically present, but now they're no
longer able
kill the infected target cell. They are
no longer able to secrete cytokines
which have antiviral activities, both the
cytokine ability the ability secrete
cytokines which have antiviral effect -
that's lost - as well as the ability to
kill the cells is lost. And also their
ability to proliferate and expand
greatly after antigen stimulation is lost.
So we defined - ours was the first group
to define this T-cell exhaustion.
This was a paper we published
in 1998 actually. This is a paper that
was published from Emory University.
Alan's Zajac who was a postdoc in the lab made this discovery that T-cells are
present but they are dysfunctional and
are functionally exhausted.
One of the joys I should say of science
is that if you kind of make an
interesting discovery and then see how
it moves forward. So for us the T-cell
exhaustion part that Alan Zajac...
There was excitement in the lab
that we had made this discovery.
And allowing the possibility of maybe fixing
these cells. And then when Dan Barbara
did really that with I think with truly
seminal experiments, with the blockade,
there was huge huge excitement
in the Dan Lab. Dan was really excited , everyone in
the lab was excited that we could do
something so simple. The experiment
was very, very simple.
We had a chronically infected mouse and all Dan
did was he injected some antibody to the
mouse -- very unsophisticated experiment
that anybody could do - just a
single injection -- and then the result
really was quite striking.
After we reported the finding that T-cells
become functionally exhausted
during chronic stimulation in this mouse
model, several other investigators at
other places and also at Emory
University showed that the same finding
of T-cell exhaustion occurs in human infections.
So it was then shown that
people who are infected with HIV have
HIV specific cd8 T cells in their blood
that you can easily detect, that even in
their lymph nodes, when some some
lymph node biopsies were done, but they are
not able to kill the target cell,
so they become dysfunctional.
Other investigators showed the same thing in
chronic hepatitis C virus infection,
hepatitis B virus infection. So it became
very quickly established that human
chronic viral infections like HIV, HCV
HBV, which have very high levels of
antigen, high levels of virus and persist
for the life of the individual, unless
they get treated by the appropriate
drugs, okay ,you get this T cell
dysfunction. Also people at around the
same time who were working in cancer
models -- models in mice showed the
same thing. They showed that there is T-cell
dysfunction in the T cells which
infiltrated the tumor.
These cells are referred to as tumor
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes -- TILs) is  the
abbreviation that's used. So it was shown
that TILs also have this T-cell
dysfunction because of the chronic
stimulation by the tumor antigens, and
then oncologists who were working with
human cancer patients found the same
thing, so this phenomenon of T-cell
exhaustion which was first described in
this mouse model that we use, it's a
virus called lymphocytic Korea meningitis
virus -- you don't need to know worry about
what the name  is and what it does.
It can infect humans, it's really not
but it's a wonderful wonderful
mouse model to study many
different aspects of the immune system.
So these studies which came out of this LC MV
mouse model of tTcell exhaustion we
quickly extended into human cancer T-cells
and in human chronic viral infections.